y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en france 24 para ello me acompaña
en el estudio daniela blandón daniela
buena noche bienvenida comenzamos
hablando porque en latinoamérica uno se
benefician de los altos precios de las
materias primas pero lamentablemente
otros no raúl muy buenas noches pues
mire los crecientes precios
internacionales tienen a varios países
de la región celebrando por ejemplo
argentina a chile brasil perú ellos son
grandes productores de commodities como
soja carne o cobre pero del otro lado de
la moneda está cuba que a pesar de haber
sido por décadas líder mundial en
producción de azúcar hoy importa el 70%
de los alimentos que consume el gobierno
ya anunció que la disponibilidad de
harina bajará en un 30% hasta julio y la
cosecha de azúcar cayó en igual
proporción a su menor nivel en más de un
ciclo pero un experto no resume esa
situación
particularmente lo que va del año los
precios de las materias primas en
algunos casos se han duplicado y en
algunos casos más que eso
y a eso se suma el aumento en el costo
de envío por lo tanto cuba está gastando
y obteniendo menos producto y es poco
probable que su cambio durante los
próximos meses todo está en contra de
cuba en 2021
daniela seguimos en américa latina' el
congreso de perú aprobó el proyecto de
ley de teletrabajo en qué consiste
bueno esta nueva ley actualiza una que
ya existía pero que el gobierno dice que
no se cumplía en el marco de la pandemia
y sólo está pendiente de su promulgación
presidencial la esencia de la norma es
que establece que la modalidad puede
establecerse siempre y cuando el
trabajador cuente con las herramientas
tecnológicas para hacer teletrabajo la
ley obliga a las empresas tanto públicas
como privadas a asumir los costos de
internet de sus empleados
y los equipos necesarios ellos también
podrán solicitar un cambio de modalidad
por trabajo presencial siempre y cuando
lo hagan con 10 días de anticipación y
atención a esto raúl uno de los puntos
más llamativos es que los empleados
tienen derecho a la desconexión digital
en horas no laborales eso quiere decir
que no están obligados a responder
llamadas ni mensajes cuando no estén en
horario laboral lo importante es que se
cumplan así desde esta equilibra decir
está desconexión es muy difícil que se
cumpla hoy en dia daniela toma fuerza la
propuesta del impuesto global a las
multinacionales bueno el departamento
del tesoro de eeuu ya le puso una cifra
15 por ciento sobre las ganancias y la
unión europea se mostró de acuerdo uno
de los objetivos es que muchas empresas
dejen de acudir a ciertas jurisdicciones
para pagar menos impuestos veamos a raúl
en las 50 mayores empresas del mundo
según su valor en bolsa representan un
28 por ciento del tipo mundial entre
ellas están por ejemplo apple
la petrolera aramco microsoft amazon y
alphabet que es la matriz de google
en los últimos 30 años su promedio de
ganancias ha ido en aumento pero la tasa
de promedio de impuestos ha bajado del
35 al 17 4% ahora vamos a hacer un
ejercicio si se implementara este
impuesto global una empresa como amazon
que vale más de un billón y medio de
dólares en bolsa tuvo ganancias por
21.000 millones en 2020 tendría que
aportar más de 3 mil millones de dólares
daniela y el fondo monetario
internacional urge a la vacunación en
los países más pobres la entidad valoró
en 50 mil millones de dólares las
necesidades de inversión para garantizar
la vacunación del 40 por ciento de la
población mundial esto antes de que
acabe este año de ese total 35 mil
millones serían financiados por aportes
de las economías avanzadas y el sector
privado el restante con préstamos de
multilaterales como el banco mundial o
el mismo fm y si el plan funciona el 60%
de la población podría estar inoculada
para junio de 2022 e indicadores daniela
como cierran las bolsas de final de la
semana
bueno wall street en cerró una semana
bastante
marcada por signos de un brote de
inflación que tiene muy preocupado al
mercado no solamente en eeuu sino en
todo el mundo europa cerró la semana en
verde por cuenta de buenos datos sobre
el crecimiento empresarial en la región
con españa acumulando seis semanas de
ganancias y buenos resultados semanales
también en latinoamérica liderados por
argentinas radiales muchísimas gracias
entonces por toda la información
económica como siempre feliz fin de
semana usted es también feliz fin de
semana buena noche y continua con
nosotros
[Música]